the french prime minister warned anyone
blocking the streets of paris would be
arrested
keeping to that word police and armored
vehicles moved into place friday as the
so-called european freedom convoy was
expected to arrive
those in the french convoy and their
supporters at locations outside of paris
appear unfazed jovial even
[Music]
when asked about the convoy and support
for it there are some common talking
points canadians they
kind of federate all the people so
that's why they're in australia in new
zealand and now in europe and in france
the people look at it and i guess it
really pushed them to to go on the
street
the words canadians freedom and fairer
world are often cited it's unclear if
there's any coordination between all of
the convoys there is cross-promotion of
different country events on the european
social media page
the demonstrators call for freedom but
in france many covet 19 restrictions
have been removed outdoor masking was
dropped earlier this month and by the
end of february there won't be any
requirements indoors at bars or
restaurants although the vaccine
passport will still be needed
i see that we've had significant loss of
freedom in the past two years and it's
important that people mobilize
those who have mobilized have so far
been prevented from entering city limits
crystal gomansing global news london